live so the pandemic is pumping new life
into thrifting
as habits change local thrift stores are
thriving they're offering bargains as
donations pile up
yeah and that's what people who run
pages like thrifters anonymous
youtube channels say our hector mejia
went bargain shopping and has the story
it's happening almost daily thrift
stores sorting through mountains of
donations people are shopping online
more
replacing things or just simply cleaning
out their home
on the other end of this it's really
helping out families who are just
trying to survive the pandemic i feel
like the stigma has changed everybody is
price conscious
edwina and shayna live and breathe the
second hand lifestyle
this is old but people see how i feel in
it the compliments come
the confidence comes and then we're
addicted pants for your child
pants for your husband with record
levels of unemployment
new families are thrifting their way
through the pandemic
so we turn to these pros for advice make
a plan
yeah you gotta follow some of your
favorite stores in town
on facebook on instagram they they host
little lives and they'll tell you
exactly the sections of the store that
are on sale the dollars spent here at
faith lutheran thrift store
mostly fund student scholarships
proceeds also pay for unexpected
last minute needs on campus look at this
this is so
cute oh my god look at i mean you're
like photograph ready
over at dinosaurs and roses the
non-profit there led struggling families
shop for free on certain days but a
referral is needed
this program helped nearly a thousand
people over the last year
we couldn't afford anything we were also
the i was one of those kids who came
into this store
needing help sabrina siri thompson helps
run this place which also funds
scholarships
founder and executive director michelle
morgan tells us
they sent over 500 students to private
school over the last year
these children never dreamed in a
million years that they would end up in
private school
back to shaina and edwina the duo says
they do get criticized
unfortunately for writing and posting
about their fun
bargain adventures on youtube they make
fun of you
i can't believe you're wearing that
dress from goodwill for a dollar at work
i used to grow up and
and i was embarrassed to wear somebody's
old pair of jeans and today
i can't wait to wear somebody's whole
pair of jeans i'm like hurry up so i can
wear those old pair of jeans
so just go thrifting with a friend and
have fun with it maybe
just maybe you'll find something you
really need like this vintage
fondue pot hector mejia reporting hate
news now